[Musique]
y'a qu'la motors champion du monde poids
moyens comme un fils et deux passes mais
sans titre en jeu la d3 devant le
français de rando tuiles dauthuile qui
est ici de dos à l'initiative des
attaques et parents lorsque procéder
demain lancée à pleine puissance
[Applaudissements]
lamotte a riposté par des directs du
gauche qui sans faire grosse impression
vont s'ouvrir les deux promettent
d'autres il
[Applaudissements]
le français a nettement l'avantagé aux
points mais ces brins deviennent lourds
par instants puis dans le web selon ses
dires et partira cependant de nouvelles
séries de double prochain la face
[Applaudissements]
la motta joue la comédie est paré subir
une correction mais brusquement et
contre attaque avec sa fameuse série de
crochets au corps et à la tête
odile qui s'est battue sans réserve
lescoules soudain à 23 secondes du
dernier fut bande qui avait freiné sa
victoire ce sont alors les seconds
inexorable qu'il entend compter et aux
portes mêmes de la victoire lorànt
deutsch il connaît la plus terrible
parce que la plus inattendue des
défaites
jake la motta douleur champion du monde
et sa joie est aussi grande que la
déception et la stupeur des supporters
de laurent mauduit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]